I strongly advise you to look through the
paper and understand both the link list version
as well as the previous Anderson's array based
lock version of the queuing locks. Because there
are lots of subtleties in implementing these kinds
of algorithms in the kernel and in the
parallel operating system kernel. And therefore, it is
important that you understand the subtleties by looking at
the code. I've given you, of course, a description
at a semantic level of what happens, but looking
at the code will actually make it very clear
what is going on in terms of writing a synchronization
algorithm on a multiprocessor. And one of the things
that I mentioned is that both the the link list
based queuing lock as well as the earlier array
based queuing lock required fancier re-modified write instruction. So for
instance, in this case, we need a fetch and store, and in this case and also a
compare and swap to fancier re-modified write instruct, instructions.
And similarly the array based queuing log required a
fetch and increment. Now it is possible that the
architecture doesn't have that. If that is the case
then you have to simulate these fancier read, modify,
write instructions using a simpler test and sentence structure.